a lot of people with cats and gardens
put these wires around
you know
around their gardens and they put this
collar around the cat's neck
and the cats then wander around not
knowing what's going on they get near to
this wire and they get an electric shock
but after about a week or two the cats
don't go near those wires
and what we've now got in our culture is
those wires now are all over the place
so so we've all got these little collars
around us
you know electrocuting us but the worst
thing is we now know don't even know
where they are
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our guest today is a practicing
and published psychotherapist andrew
thomas welcome to trigonometry well
thank you welcome why am i saying well
it's kind of it's great you've taken
over the space you feel right at home
you did allude to the fact that you
worked with couples uh before we started
and you said this felt a little bit like
it and i did complain there's not enough
sex in this relationship well we can
work on that afterwards
we can put a half hour into that i
absolutely hope so we need to tell you
about get more love into this but look
uh joking aside it's great to have you
on uh i'll be honest with our audience
we we got you on because you got in
touch with us and you had some very
interesting things you wanted to talk to
us about uh from a psychotherapist's
perspective but particularly relevant to
the political context and one of those
things uh was the idea that people
live
right and vote left so talk to us about
that so
we have across the western world now
a large part of the middle classes
who
the way they live their lives is is
from my perspective admirable they they
they're resilient they take
responsibility for their outcomes in
their lives they work really hard
um
uh
they if they meet uh
uh obstacles
in the way they try to overcome them in
fact they really largely look into
themselves for the resilience and the
resources
uh and the capacity to learn
to overcome the problems and and achieve
what they're hoping to achieve
and the other thing is they raise their
children in that light
so they raise their children to be
resilient resourceful
adaptive
but when they go into the voting booth
they vote for parties that promote
policies and a cultural outlook that are
largely in many ways diametrically
opposite to the way they actually live
their lives themselves
i mean it's not to be too political you
know we have the classic case of diane
abbott doyen of the left
who's whose son
went to a private school
so the way she actually lived her life
as it can be or lives her life she
hasn't gone yet uh lives her life
compared to how she actually votes and
and the types of policy support the
diametrically
opposite so this is very interesting
andrew because what this is one of the
things that i've been kind of
chronicling in some of the articles i've
written and in my book that i'm working
on etc which is that
there is a often an inconsistency
between the things that people do and
the things that people say
one ought to do or that you ought to do
so
what is your theory about why that's
happening well
just say i mean i'm increasingly uneasy
about the labeling virtue signaler and
woke and all the rest of it
i mean if it take diane abbott i mean
what achievements she's had in her life
you know what what barriers she's broken
down and overcome and and i'm i'm
increasingly uneasy about how people are
so that the polarization and the
labeling that's going on
but the drivers behind that uh are
there's a number of core if you want me
to talk about the sort of psycho
psychological
the sort of and also the evolutionary
psychological and the neuroscientific
drivers behind that
is that we we have there's two things
that that um
genetics are an important factor in our
propensity to experience anxiety
depression so if you read a book called
blueprint by robert plowman you'll see a
wonderful
a resume and a coverage of where we are
in understanding that but it's looking
really very convincing that our genetics
are very influential but it's also how
they interact with the environment
if you
put an environment around young children
that's chaotic uncertain
where their attachment is being switched
on switched off
uh you're going to start to get more and
more children growing into adults who
demonstrate of what you know
sort of what we would say maladaptive
avoidant behavioural patterns
so
the study has been done that that people
who have got left of center leanings
have got a greater propensity towards
anxiety and seeing the world through
what i would call a floppy lens
so so
what do i mean by a floppy lens well
there
there's a tendency to trigger into a
survival type of pattern
so
imagine a hundred thousand years ago
you're walking through the bush to pick
uh berries or whatever you come to a
clearing and on the other side uh
there's a berry bush
but it's moving in a strange way all the
birds have gone a bit quiet and there's
nothing else moving what happens is you
focus so everything focuses
so you focus on the bush
the next thing is you overreact so your
your survival system you start to get
adrenaline pumping through your system
so you overreact so you get f you focus
you overreact and p is you become
pessimistic
so we know from david attenborough
documentaries that there are far more
antelope than there are tigers
but you'll be pessimistic because you'll
see
that the bush is likely to have behind
it the most incredibly big tiger that
hasn't eaten for three weeks
with a taste just for you so you focus
you overreact it
you're pessimistic and you get it as a
package the reason you get is a package
is it's no use focusing and being
pessimistic if you don't overreact
because if that lion comes out
and you haven't started to overreact it
might make five meters to you before
your adrenaline system starts going
okay
and so
that could be the difference between you
getting your dna into the next
generation or not so you you focus you
overreact you pessimistic you get is it
a package and the eye is it's inaccurate
and the reason why evolution has made
that
inaccurate is 100 000 years ago
you could be you could run away many
times but only eaten once it's better to
overreact just in case if you're safe so
so that is a survival system that's in
every single one of us 7.8 billion of us
that we've got that in us
so if you then couple that with a uh an
early stage development
kind of sound to be clinical the system
uh
early stage family life for for um
children where
is dad there or dad not there is dad
looking at the mobile phone his dad not
looking at the mobile phone his mum
there no is is she there or not there
you know oh where did dad go there's a
there's a new man in the house or
whatever so that is likely to develop a
higher proportion of your society
with a heightened foppy reaction to the
world around them and has that happened
have people been growing up in
increasingly unstable
childhood environments
uh well yeah since the 1950s yeah it
looks like
what what you're saying is i mean this
isn't sort of saying you know there's a
stereotypical if you're like this it's
going to be dreadful
but but overall the the challenge of
raising a child
i mean the correlation between
single-parent families and all sorts of
things that that happen in life is is is
not good because it's incredibly
challenging to raise a child by yourself
there are many single parents that do
that but they're also now because i sit
in rooms with couples that have you know
for thousands of hours
it's not confined just to single
parenting you know the pressures this
this self-actualizing goal
that that generates this incredible high
hours working culture
where
whatever car you've got
you know whatever look you've got you
know you know that you've managed to
attain will will fade quite quickly
so
so
so we do have a society that in in many
ways is sort of
set to generate a proportion of the you
know coming back to the irony if you
look at the middle classes
their goal is stability you know they do
whatever they can to create a stable
environment around their children you
could say somewhere over the top you
know tiger and tiger parents
but but the outcome of a lot of policies
today is to create incredible
uncertainty in a lot of households
which the survival system the attachment
system of young children especially the
age of two three four five
are hypersensitive to
and and at those ages they're
experimenting with different behavioral
patterns
so if mum or dad
are unavailable
or incredibly angry
then they may experiment with a shutdown
type of survival system which is to self
anesthetize
or they may start to experiment and
develop what i call a legacy behavior
which is an acting out type of
behavioral pattern which is dragging the
attention of the parent back onto them
in any way that system can do
so
so if you've got a society a culture
that's generating
sort of uh more fragile
more floppy orientated
styles of behavior
and then along comes that naughties and
we have social media
we have
the capacity and i'm coming back on to
the middle classes now so if you've got
a greater proportion of the middle
classes
who are likely to trigger a lower level
of activation into a floppy-like
response if you get that and then you
ram social media into that and the the
incredible oled screens and high
definition and surround sound
and then you allow then people get into
their own silos because it's much less
threatening to be out of your silo
what you're going to do is you're going
to get people um
sort of triggering and trying to find
ways to rid themselves of the discomfort
in terms of the dichotomy between their
comfortable lives and the chaos terror
the burning fires in australia or
california and their comfortable lives
and so
if you have a tendency to trigger
into a fopulite state
you're going to really just reach out
for really quite sort of
immediate solutions to calm yourself so
you'll be looking for avoidant styles of
behavior also if your neighbors are
talking about how dreadful the world is
how the world's going to come to an end
you know very soon
then again remember that attachment
metric is playing out in those
relationships as well
but isn't there also a vested interest
in society because the more
floppy-like behavior people have the
more likely they are to be good
consumers
to buy things to desire things to to
this constant consumption that we have
in our society which is necessary to
keep the economy growing
well absolutely yeah yeah i mean if if
it's self-actualization which is is
which is the never-achievable goal
i mean if you go out and buy a book on
meditation and two years later you're
about yourself levitating above some
glass like andean lake
and out of the corner of your eye you
see sting with trudy having tantric sex
four foot above the lake
you know
what are you gonna do you've somehow got
to do your meditation even better now
this isn't this avoidant way of looking
at things the driver it isn't realistic
it isn't sort of
well we should not try to do anything
it's more about actually being able to
look at the drivers for your behavior
and look at them that they are driven by
your behavioral patterns
by how your system got trained
by this this whole physiology this whole
neuroscience this whole neurological
system
which you've got
and that
it means that if you've got it and
that's what's driving it you've actually
got the hands on the levers so that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't
try your best push yourself as hard as
you can
but that goal that drive can come out of
much more understanding of
whether of how positive or negative it
is for you in your life given how you
are and the resources you've got rather
than just being handed down
this existential goal that maslow came
up with
in 1943 in many ways isn't the pinnacle
of self-actualization
social media
where you can actually
curate
the
the way you want people to see you the
way you want to be viewed who you are
if you look at something like instagram
you can physically change the way you
look you can create this life which
actually has
no bearing on your real life whatsoever
it's the it's the pinnacle of avoidance
it allows you to sculpt your avoidant
behavior in any way shape or form you
like
i mean that that
i mean jeff bezo not jeff bezo who's the
fa
the facebook guy oh zuckerberg
zuckerberg i mean he probably thinks
he's the greatest business person ever
in the whole wide world i mean his band
balance would say sir yeah well it would
do but
this avoidant style of behavior isn't
recent it's been going uh the first
homie is sapiens 200 000 years ago we
developed language well 50 to 100 000
years ago
it you know that the the we've wanted to
have the best possible level of
attachment we can have with the people
around us
for a hundred thousand years
and along come social media and hey
presto you can
you you're in a society that is is
slicing and dicing what's acceptable and
what's not acceptable and hey presto you
can just suddenly find other people
who've got the same avoidant behavioural
patterns as you have
so
you know zuckerberg may have thought
well god i've created this incredible
thing that i've pushed onto it but the
human race has just been gagging for
facebook for a couple of hundred
thousand years
you know it's it it fed into a
phenomenal demand but that demand has
also been
driven
by the you know this this culture of uh
you know the right way to speak the
right way to look the right way to
behave and if you look at the education
of young children now
or males or female whatever
there are so many criteria now that
that mean you're either in or you're out
i mean i don't know if you you know any
people with cats well people a lot of
people with cats and gardens put these
wires around
you know
around their gardens and they put this
collar around the cat's neck
and the cats then wander around not
knowing what's going on they get near to
this wire and they get an electric shock
but after about a week or two the cats
don't go near those wires
and what we've now got in our culture is
those wires now are all over the place
so so we've all got these little collars
around us
you know electrocuting us but the worst
thing is we now know don't even know
where they are
it's so good that you bring that up
because as you know it's one of the
things we've talked a lot about on the
show which is the idea of freedom of
expression freedom of speech uh why
suddenly it seems like to me at least
uh things that we used to all be able to
to to to debate to discuss to
let people have wrong opinions to let
people have bad opinions to let people
have whatever opinions they wanted i
mean look at you know there's a lot of
talk now about how we've got to shut
down conspiracy theories and ideas about
what's causing the pandemic or why are
there lockdowns or why is this and why
is that well it was 20 years ago you had
911
a huge terrorist attack loads of
conspiracy theories flying about all the
time it never occurred to anyone that
they should be shut down i remember
watching conspiracy uh documentaries
about 911 on on on social media or on uh
later in the day but also on tv it was
considered a normal part of the social
discourse about things that people are
allowed to have different thoughts about
different things even if they're
completely wrong and yet we've got to a
position where now
we seem to desire a massive crackdown on
that but if you if you look at that
through the lens of the live right vote
left middle classes
who who have their handles on the levers
of power in society they're they're in
the think tanks they're in the schools
they're in the universities they're they
they're the sort of people who become
mps be they labor lib dem or
conservative those those live right vote
left well maybe not the conservatives
but you know
also the conservatives now yeah well
possibly yeah yeah yeah freudian slip
there uh
so
so but if you look at it
the the the the um
cognitive dissonance that's possible for
them
which is a are you aware with cognitive
dissonance yes
no wonder they don't want to talk to
their friends about politics or
economics that maybe see things
differently because that might generate
a sense of cognitive dissonance between
their how they live and how they vote
that will generate it generates a sort
of floppy type reaction people get
triggered up so that's why you see the
middle class circles uh you know
whatever if ever people shying away from
talking about politics because it's
really uncomfortable
i mean that if you i don't know how
we're going to get through this but if
you look at the 1970s that was a
wonderful example of cognitive
dissonance people think that margaret
thatcher came in and she was this
incredible leader with this vision i see
it slightly differently is that in the
1970s
people who'd bought into socialism
nationalization state control sort of
the state could somehow define which
industries were the best to go in
to and invest in well in the 1970s those
very same people ended up walking past
piles of rubbish
or lighting their homes with candles
or experiencing three day weeks or i
think it was in 1917 29 million days of
of strikes
and that was an incredible cognitive
dissonant experience that challenged
their views
and that is what i think margaret
thatcher
was able to build on
she was
she was able to the the the she came
into a society that had in a way been
partially reconditioned
and at the moment what we have is a
society that enables people
you know through uh
the incredible printing presses you know
modern modern modern monetary theory
uh that enables us to insulate ourselves
from whatever views might we might want
because theoretically society is so
incredibly wealthy
in other words
we can advocate let's say just
hypothetically speaking for open borders
without thinking of the consequences
that that would have on the country
let's say not least because we are
insulated ourselves from them well the
people in power the the and the middle
classes that may hold those those views
were might live in very leafy
monocultural
environments
they have maybe the muscle the financial
muscle to buy houses in
the catchment area of the best schools
their their children will typically go
to russell group universities they'll
compete for jobs uh
you know the that require very high
levels of english skills that maybe
aren't competing at the the other end
but
but
but i don't hold that
you know if you look at those people
they're models of industriousness i mean
that's the problem when you when you
when you start to go down that rabbit
hole you can start to become condemning
but but they actually
they actually mimic you know really
ideal behaviors
what i would be condemning is advocating
for things without with no regard for
the impact of those things yes people i
am happy to engage in discussion with
these people i don't believe they're
disgusting i don't believe that they're
immoral i just think that they are
mistaken and if we were to have a
conversation
i hope that we could change each other's
minds and come to a compromise what i
have found though one of my best friends
is uh you know
one of these kind of
almost loony lefties if you like yeah
and whenever we have a conversation
i've got him to say this many times i go
look but you look i'm an immigrant right
you realize that when you allow large
numbers of people to come into a country
without the opportunity to integrate
properly causes problems don't you he'll
go yes yes yes and then and i talk him
through the whole thing and he goes look
i understand all of that i just think we
should have open borders
what we're witnessing there is an
avoidant behavioral pattern right
so so what's driving him to behave like
that which you find frustrating i mean
if you were really
what i'm hearing for a lot of people in
this situation if they try to engage in
people who who do the live right vote
left stuff if you if you maybe your
friend doesn't doesn't sort of live
right i don't know but
but what what they're experiencing is
they get very upset very quickly
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you've got you've got a good
point there yeah they do they do so so
so so and that and what you're
witnessing is an avoidant
behavioural plan because it's
conversation over yes yeah it's
conversation over let's split up let's
move apart and let's not address it but
that but that is a survival orientated
you know that's an avoidant orientated
behavioral so what can we do about that
as a society because it seems to me that
it's quite important for people to be
able to discuss
practical ideas about the direction of
travel do we take a left turn do we take
a right turn do we keep going straight
do we slam on the brakes that to me is a
practical conversation about ensuring
the well-being of everybody going
forward particularly our children
grandchildren etc we've got important
decisions to make as a society right
yeah so how do we how do we bridge those
divides how would how do we
within ourselves and particularly with
other people
well i'd like to say we we shift away
from maslow's conception at the higher
end that it's self-actualization
and we move to a more accurate and sort
of a more
uh accurate
model of what human motivation and human
drive is really made up of
okay
and
and move to a place where more of us
uh
many more of us in the west are aware of
what drives our emotional life what
causes us to trigger
so so for your good friend who says well
blah blah blah well it doesn't does he
get he doesn't sound like he gets really
angry but he almost sounds like he sort
of withdraws he sort of shuts down from
the debate you know which is another
avoidance style of behavior he sort of
self-anesthetizes it because he just
doesn't want to go there yes because to
touch on that live rail
janet would really generate a lot of
discomfort so if he could become more
aware
of uh
how he triggers
around these subjects
so so he could actually notice is i
developed this other model which is the
reflective mind reactive brain and
reactive body
so
you know this system is phenomenally
complex
and you can go on training courses now
that pick up individual parts of the
brain and they say it does this or that
so what i decided to do
in in my work was create a model that
enabled clients to really just see the
basic core
system of the hume of the human which is
a reflect capacity to be reflective the
reflective mind
the reactive brain which is going all
the time yours is going on at the time
you know what is this guy going on about
whatever you're asking it to do that
it's just ramming
narrative and sensations
you know narrative into the surface of
your brain and sensations across your
body so you've got a reactive body and a
reactive brain that's constantly
interacting
so if we can a lot of the work i'm doing
now and and other therapists are using
the rainbow map or if you want to go
sensory motor therapy
is that we're trying to enable our
clients to notice their system
triggering
so so i've got this one concept which is
called a trigger flag which is typically
a physical sensation
so so as a lot of people trigger they
notice their throats go or the jaws go
and if you can notice yourself
triggering
or withdrawing
you can actually then exert a little bit
more choice about whether oh okay
you know here goes constantine
this is the experience i've got i feel
really uneasy about this i just want to
shut this conversation down i don't want
to go there
if you can actually notice that that
that that that driver
then you can exert more choice about
whether you obey it
or overrule it
so
there's two ways out of this that we've
got in the west we're either going to go
through a 1970s and we're going to get
cognitive dissonance
there's going to be widespread
it wasn't meant to work like this i mean
a lot of people are starting to look at
it like that aren't they
that hold on you know
so if we were
you know if if we were trying to clear
the area like like we we've made
everyone able to get a degree now
now last year whether he turned up to
university or not you know that
that that uh
that whole thing you know of
self-actualization if self-actualization
you know
the politicians of the last 30 years if
part of self-actualization our society
is everyone's going to get a degree
everyone can have a degree
but we're already starting to see the
cognitive dissonance getting in there
because companies can't tell the
difference now
and degrees are going down and down in
value
so so
you know maybe we'll get the cognitive
dissonant bit by bit
and we'll be able to sort of turn the
corner or maybe it will be a 1970s type
of
mass cognitive dissonance where you
really see what you get when you
nationalize everything
isn't it not everything so
and the other thing is
more awareness of how your system your
survival system triggers
look
this is all very intelligent and you're
a far more intelligent man to me and
good luck to you
isn't it a question of just being
[ __ ] brave and having a little bit of
balls and saying what you think you know
we feel uncomfortable we feel
uncomfortable at certain points when i
started my teaching career i felt
uncomfortable and being in front of 30
kids but you have to do it in order to
have a career you feel uncomfortable
when you ask a woman out but otherwise
you're never going to get have sex
why is it that we now have a culture
where we feel
bad about being uncomfortable life's
uncomfortable isn't it are we just
getting older yeah yeah but we've all
got metaphors
we've all got metaphorical collars
around our necks that electrocute
ourselves
so so you've got lovely you know the
this stuff about the you know the the
the the live right vote left mill
classes
we've all got friends like that
and we we love them and like them you
know and and connect very strongly
and if you come out and i've tried it a
few times if you come out and try to
challenge them i mean
this is a cult
you know they're they'll double down
and you'll lose your friends
you know that's the way it seems at the
moment i mean
you know how do you actually try to
engage in conversations with people who
if they start to get into that
conversation will become increasingly
uncomfortable because of that cognitive
dissonance i i mean it's a it's a it's a
psychological driver for them they truly
you know they trigger
and then then the reflective mind starts
shutting down so with your friend the
ref the capacity to be reflective starts
to
to to go down and the reactive brain and
reactive body start to dominate i mean
i'll give you a quick example in this i
mean the the door to this room is over
there
okay
if that handle goes down i can guarantee
you instantaneously every single one of
our reflective minds will shut
instantaneously because we'll turn look
around there and that's an example of
compulsive behavior and that's what
you're dealing with so as you start with
your friend you say come on you're just
just wrong you know come on look at this
look at this
how does that work
not very well i'll be honest with you
yeah
and and
do you think that school has got a part
to play in this and the way we raise
kids well we want kids to be safe we
want to protect them and i've seen it in
schools that i've taught in you know we
want to modify them we want them to be
as safe as possible all the time every
single minute of every day so that when
they actually get confronted
by
you know a challenge or a disagreement
they don't know how to deal with it well
we we've got you know this safety
culture you know a sort of
sort of uh in a way an exploitation
of uh balbi's uh attachment theory from
1958
we we've got a society now that that is
you know social workers psychologists
who are so well versed in attachment
with the view that that if you if you
have any level of detachment we've got
to somehow stop that
but but but where i think we're getting
it wrong it's the direction that the
detachment i mean i think it would have
been better if he called it detachment
theory
because from a survival perspective you
can't be breastfeeding when you're 20.
you know a hundred thousand years ago
you know you're doing a hunt and the
tiger store the antelope say oh just
wait i've got a break because i need to
go to mum to have a bit of a top-up i
mean it wasn't really a survival
orientated
advantageous way of behaving so from the
point of birth
that's the the child has to learn to
detach from the parent
so what we're sort of getting sort of
mixed up is is a clear understanding of
where that detachment comes from
so if the parents are very stable
they're there it's the the healthy form
of detachment if it's engineered from
the child's end
okay so the child experiments at two or
three or four and they push more and
more distance between them but they know
if they want to turn around and come
back that security is there
but on the other hand you also need you
also need elements of parental forced
attachment
so oh my god you know the parent isn't
there
it it depends on frequency and degree
you know if the if the parent is
constantly detaching and doing it to a
really brutal extent
then you're likely to train that child
survival system into developing
maladaptive behavioral patterns
but but what we can't do as society or
parents is is is in a way say you know
protect the children you know give
people
trigger warnings all over the place i
mean the the actual experience of being
triggered of being upset is a
developmental experience
i mean i'm not it's all about degrees
isn't it when you say it's a
developmental experience just to
translate it into simple language what
you mean is you have to go through life
and experience being triggered quote
unquote in order to grow
yes
yeah um
i can give you a little bit more no no
that's good i think i think i i think
the simple yes is good though i was just
about to go off into it all yes so so
you need to
like i mean francis was saying this you
need to experience discomfort in order
to be a fully fleshed human being i know
this from my own life and this is why
this whole ideology to some extent this
is why we've been talking about this
stuff
i know that almost everything that i've
ever done in my life that's been
worthwhile in my opinion has involved
extreme discomfort at some level
every single thing whether it's work
whether it's relationship whether it's
my own personal development as a human
being whether it's reading an important
book right it's required discipline and
sticking with it and sometimes reading a
bit that i wasn't interested like do you
see what i'm saying
this idea that we must avoid discomfort
as the greatest
objective of our existence
is absurd but there's a more fundamental
driver and need behind that as well
because
uh
you know
i talked to you about those what i why i
called trigger packages earlier if
if you uh 100 000 years ago if you're
four years old there's a forest fire
comes in you smell the acrid smoke you
see the experience the expressions of
the faces around you you feel the heat
and you hear the screaming and you
managed to just get out with your life
you the trauma-based learning system is
going to create trigger packages that
will endure for the rest of your life
why because
you don't experience another forest fire
for the next 20 or 30 years you know you
happen to be 32 or 33 you get the
faintest whiff of acrid smoke and bingo
you get that experience that that
incredibly powerful visceral experience
and you become alert to what's going on
around you and you're warmth forewarned
and you get the hell out
okay
evolution has it those trigger packages
are incredibly resilient they don't
shift but the other thing about them is
they are recon they can be reconditioned
when they crack open
so a lot of
therapeutic approaches today like cbt or
intake cognitive behavioral theory
uh
therapy orientated towards phobias is
actually causing the person to trigger
in a sort of minor way and then an
increasing way around say spiders or
flying or whatever because what it's
actually doing is cracking open that
trigger package but in a manageable way
and then piling in new narratives
so so when it shuts down again it's less
potent
and when it opens up again there will be
maybe other narratives some more
restorative uh resources so it doesn't
overwhelm you so to come back to you
yeah i mean
triggering uh
overcoming challenges uh
uh having upsets
uh are yeah are all really
reconditioned the opportunities to
recondition
i mean
we don't want this to say you know
abusive behavior
violence sexual abuse
those aren't constructive
experiences you know they're incredibly
damaging i'm pretty sure that's always
been universally understood yeah i think
what's happened in recent years is is an
attempt to conflate that
those things are you talking about
violence
abuse
etc with
ordinary experiences in life that's why
people now talk about language as being
violence right the words are now
considered violence by some people
because it's an attempt to conflate the
two and i think it's quite deliberate
attempt because it's a way of getting
power over other people
yeah i don't see it quite like that i i
think the people who are saying that a
lot of maybe some people are like that
but quite a lot of the people are
genuinely triggered you know that that
sense of vulnerability uh
you know the the the anxiety the fear
the pain i think is quite real
what we have to look is is how do people
end up developing to have that type of
sensitivity
so so
so yeah now i see it's like slightly
different take your point so you just to
summarize because you've already made
this point i take it your conception of
this is that people are hypersensitive
am i okay to use that term not everyone
there's a greasing proportion of society
yes they're powerfully triggered and
they are very easy to trigger
because
the unstable childhood environment they
grew up in combined with the education
system combined with blah blah blah
and social media
yeah you've got to be a bit careful with
that
because
okay parenting is a very broad spectrum
of parenting okay
so so the the the branches of parenting
that will really predictably generate
sort of discordant behavioral patterns
in life you know in the upper well upper
and lower quartiles of that sort of
distribution so
so this isn't a message to parents that
they somehow have to be perfect parents
just being okay
is largely good and then it's how your
genetics interact with the environment
that then really make the difference but
if you are starting to generate a
society where where the where the the
the electric wires are encroaching
then you're pushing more people you know
that that shape of that distribution
curve is changing
and and more and more people are
starting to
grow up with uh
triggering systems as i might call it
that are on a hairline that are
really sensitized to going off to any
perceived threat and generate really
powerful levels of discomfort
i mean it's a very very very good point
look how much of this is also a type of
narcissistic behavior as well whereby
someone goes to a comedy night for
instance they hear a joke everyone
laughs or the vast majority of people
laugh they feel it's disgusting
therefore
they want to set the parameters of what
is and what isn't acceptable
because of the way they see the world
isn't that a form of narcissism as well
well you you're
you're seeing uh you're seeing someone
behave you know driven by an attachment
form behavior you know well their
behavior
is is is really trying to in a way
reattach themselves to whoever they
perceive to be
their attachment group
so so they're experiencing you know sort
of quite a visceral sort of physical
experience or maybe narratives really
punching into their brains that are
really powerful
and a bit like your friend you know that
that joke has pushed them onto the live
wire and so now with uh social media
they can go straight to that and and
with that's a classic avoidant
behavioral pattern they'll sate their
discomfort
by going out onto social media and and
and demonstrating their virtue and that
they don't align with that type of joke
or that type of thinking and that will
calm them down well here's the thing
though because france's question i think
is very good because
i remember a situation where i was
performing in a comedy show and my wife
was there
and she had literally just come back
from ukraine from her grandmother's
funeral
and the comedian who was on before me
was doing material
pretty funny material about pushing his
grandmother down the stairs he was a
comedy yeah yeah and my wife being a
normal person obviously you know she was
feeling a bit raw her grandmother who
was important in her life had just died
got up went to the toilet got a drink of
water waited for this comedian to get
off stage came back in the room and
watched the rest of the show right she
was not untriggered by him making jokes
about a very raw subject for her at that
time yeah but it never occurred to her
to go on social media and to sate her
whatever
in that way so what is the difference
between her and someone who feels that's
why i think francis is getting that when
he talks about narcissism well a couple
of things you know how well does it work
when you write an article and you label
group people narcissist i mean how
convincing is that how to how do they
how do people react when you sort of
label them with really quite negative
sort of we're just asking you the
question yeah i to me it's not a
question of persuasiveness to me it's a
question of accuracy
is it accurate or not to say that partly
this is driven by narcissism i i suppose
what you're looking at you're talking to
is the person who is looking at the
behavioral patterns and the drivers
behind that
which is i mean i in the couple work i
do you know the the hundreds and
hundreds of couples i've sat with you
know far more difficult than the two of
you
you know over the years
and they you know
and because they they're coming in
they're talking about the real nuts and
bolts of what's happening in their
relationships and then they talk about
one of their child their children who's
just been labeled adhd
or
some other label that's been given to
them by a child psychologist now there
probably are children with adhd or
abnormal but if that child psychologist
were to really hear what i've heard
about what's really going on in that
family they would marvel that kid even
gets out of bed in the morning
you know when you hear what goes you
know i hear stuff that you just wouldn't
believe
and so we're so we're mislabeling people
all over the place in our society today
i mean it's an easy thing to do isn't it
you know it just is a label person i
mean i've been guilty of it until about
six to nine months ago
you know because you know my thinking
around this has always been involving
you know uh
you know i might have been calling
people virtue signals i don't really do
that now you know i don't do that
because i just think that
the people i think about who who are
virtual are actually really great people
but i'm not saying people but they
trigger
but they they tr they trigger and they
have to be able to describe things
accurately though i i get this whole not
just everything
i get it but but at the same time i
personally know people and i know in
myself the temptation to signal virtue
on social media i know it in myself
right yeah it exists in all of us i
would never do that no sure
right well that's a great virtue
so so this is my point is we all have
the instinct in us
to get attention from
the community the society to attach to
attack right
so
to to say that somebody is engaging in
virtue signaling is not to say that
they're a bad person or that they're
immoral it is to say that they're
engaging in a behavior that i recognize
look i think we're
well three of us we're all seeing you
know this this the this identity and
culture
where minority groups are being
convinced that any problems
that they have in their lives have got
nothing to do with them
you know it's got everything to do with
the society around them i'm not saying
you know society doesn't have its
problems and and don't don't negatively
influence groups but to send a message
to certain
minority groups or groups of people that
it's nothing to do with you you know
don't ever look at your behavior just
look outside of yourself well yeah that
is incredibly damaging
but i i the reason why i'm quite like
the uh live right vote left is it's
actually descriptive of the behavior
sure yeah
whereas uh virtue signal is a sort of
quite a pejorative term but where you
could argue yeah well that's actually a
description of the behavior i suppose
but
so it sort of have a sense that it's
quite sort of just quite pejorative you
know it's quite it's a put down isn't it
and i have to say i've been guilty of
that myself in years gone by
but it it doesn't work it just
pisses people off hmm
no it's what if you want to piss them
off yeah i mean
go for it yeah
then you drive engagement on social
media you know that's the way to do it
and we gotta wrap up then there's one
more question that i wanted to ask right
which is this
why have we started to conflate mental
health with mental illness
and we use these two terms
interchangeably when they obviously have
very very different meanings well if you
read a book called black rainbow by
um oh what's her name uh rachel it will
come to me black rainbow it's about this
times journalists
journey through her mental illness
over 20 years and if you ever want to
get an understanding of what is the
difference you know what is mental
health what really is mental illness
read that book
you know because she eviscerates herself
you may not
you know she's very wealthy
has got the ideal life but but she turns
her pen on herself
in the most unremitting way and you and
if ever you want to get an understanding
what the difference is i mean
basically mental illness mental health
is is you you're basically engaging in
behavioral patterns that are getting in
the way of you experiencing your life in
the way you want to
getting up and being a bit sad in the
morning is something different
but
you know i think in this i've seen a
scene listen to a few podcasts you ask
at the you know if you want to ask me
that final question you'd do i might i
might be able to respond to that a
little bit more what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be seamless uh yeah grace
i think it's a the way people in public
eye are talking about the experience of
psychotherapy
uh
it's great so i mean it's it's fine to
say hey i've been see a psychotherapist
or or you know i went with you know i
had i had these issues
but what we're starting to see is people
talk about what they actually talk about
in the psychotherapy session
you know in the public eye they're
they're talking about relations or what
people did or what people said
and what they're doing unwittingly
probably is they're weaponizing the
actual psychotherapy session
and one of the most precious things
about psychotherapy in our culture today
is
is the perception that if you sit with
someone like me or any of my peers who
are in the mainstream therapeutic
organization the bacp
uh you know any of these sort of
psychological mainstream we're all
really tied into really strong senses of
ethics around confidentiality
and if we start to challenge
you know through what we talk about that
actually happens in the session publicly
then
you're starting to create an impression
that you know what's talked about in
there can just be spread everywhere
and i think that's a retrograde step and
the next thing is
is is uh starting to get and i think
coming back to your question francis
it's starting to get bit more of a gauge
about when they're accessing
psychotherapy
so so it's okay to feel a bit sad at
times it's okay to feel a bit angry at
times you know that's not a mental
illness if you if you're being angry all
the time and sad all the time yeah
that's that could well be a problem but
i think people in the public eye need to
think a little bit more
about how they're communicating the
degree
of
uh
the the mental health issues that are
causing them to go to therapy or not
so i'd like that to be
the the awareness of how people in
public eye talk about
the reasons why they go to therapy what
happens to therapy
and the the degree of the issues that
cause them to go to therapy i think that
would uh
in a way preserve and protect
the the sanctity
and the effectiveness of therapy
regardless of how you practice it
and that is a wonderful point to end the
show thank you so much for coming on if
people want to find you where is the
best place to do that well i i'm now
you know delivering a you know public
workshops two-hour workshops oh by the
way all the training i do is not for
profit
so i charge as little as i can and a
third of all the revenues that i
generate go to the charity shelter
uh because of the connection between
mental health and homelessness
andrew thomas thank you so much for
coming on the show well thank you very
much i mean it's been really interesting
really fascinating to meet you and talk
to you thank you very much likewise and
uh thank you for watching and listening
we will see you very soon with another
interview uh all of them go out at 7 00
pm uk time and of course you can catch a
raw show as well we've got those four
nights a week 7 p.m uk time 2 p.m
eastern take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below